a medida que las campañas avanzan crece
la confianza en las vacunas así lo
reveló un estudio elaborado por yougov y
el imperial college london basado en
consultas a 13 mil 500 personas de 15
países en relación con la misma encuesta
realizada en noviembre la cantidad de
personas dispuestas a vacunarse de
inmediato creció del 41 al 54 por ciento
un dato que se incrementó en 11 de los
15 países relevados en cuanto a la
confianza en las vacunas italia encabeza
el registro con 82 por ciento seguido
por reino unido con 81 en 14 de los 15
países relevados más de la mitad de los
encuestados respaldan las vacunas vacuna
es algo positivo porque
ayuda a combatir la pandemia
por un tema de salud
estamos haciendo un gran trabajo para
salir de esto y no puedo esperar a
obtener la mía tengo mi brazo lista y el
escepticismo se mantiene alto en países
como francia que registró el mayor
número de personas que no se aplicaría
en la vacuna con 44%
no obstante duplicó al 30% la cantidad
de personas totalmente de acuerdo con
recibir la inmunización y las
sensaciones parecen estar cambiando a
medida que se realizan las vacunaciones
más gente se ofrece voluntariamente
yo diría que mi opinión ha cambiado
porque ahora me siento más favorable a
la vacuna production con el 66% de los
encuestados japón lidera la desconfianza
en las vacunas en ese país y en
australia corea del sur y singapur la
disposición a vacunarse se ha reducido
desde noviembre